好 那個謝謝大家 我今天主要講一下接著上週的話題吧
主要講一下就是最近繼續下跌的幾個因素
然後Momentum Factor這個平倉然後它大概會多久
上週其實這個東西其實就是說或者它現在評了多少
就假設它如果全部要評的話 它假設會評多少
然後什麼東西額外的風險 也是什麼樣的額外的風險
在這個Momentum Factor以外
其實首先我覺得要去覆盤一下我們以前的一些看法
其實我在5月份的時候講過到5月份
5月份的5月中暗部5月初的時候
我講過其實那個時候其實從市場基本面子算籌碼來說
它其實不太支持繼續上漲
但是後來確實是打破臉
就確實在6月份的時候還在漲
是那個Quad N
像在6月份的時候那個Quad N
那個時候要去做一個rebalance嘛
就是相當於把很多股票漲得多把股票倉位平出來
然後去買債
那個時候rebalance沒對市場造成很大影響
其實我也有點疏忽
就我覺得那個時候可能市場確實流行性特別特別好
然後但其實不是
就是說我們現在要回去看那個Momentum這個
事情的影響
其實要回到那個世界
就是為什麼6月份還在漲
6月份的上漲或者是
那最後一波的上漲其實是Momentum Factor帶動了
那麼這樣就能夠理解Momentum Factor這東西到底會平倉
會平倉到一個什麼樣的水平
其實你看一下這樣的
這個是我們自己來一篇畫的有數據圖
就是說
金黃色的線和黑顏色的線我們其實之前講過
黑顏色線叫做Gross Modge
現在黃的叫做Net Modge
然後我在5、6月份的時候講這個事情的時候
我其實有個疏忽我是覺得
市場總的做多的頭村不算太多
那個時候的Net Modge高嗎
Net Modge在
那個時候可能在這裡吧
就算100%就是一不到嘛
然後Gross Modge比較高Gross Modge在300多
那個在6月初的時候300多非常高
然後
當時的感覺是說
市場就是多空的頭村在對頭村
所以
要麽就是會有一個抉擇
要麽就是找
要麽就是要麽就給跌下去
整個市場是一起波動
那你這樣看的話
在這些波動的股票裡面
那個業績好的
半導體的股票應該相對來說比較好
那這個時候的判斷我覺得
我就副盤
當時的判斷的一個可能的問題
就是其實真正的Gross Modge
它沒有發生在
對於市場
表達對市場多空的看法
它的Gross Modge更多表達在不同股票之間的看法
也就是
它的表達形式是
它買錄了半導體
然後賣出其他的股票
那這樣的倉位很重的時候
你沒有發生NetModge的
就是裸多頭
他們的確是買多
然後賣空
就相當於是量化做多了半導體
那我們一直在說Momentum
Momentum到底是怎麼樣有個事情
就是Momentum其實
就是它無腦的會去做多漲多的票
然後無腦的做空
那些跌的票
其實這個就是Momentum
我上周好像跟你們講過
你們去看一下
MSCI的那個Momentum的這個指數怎麼做
對吧
然後因為過去所有漲了多的票
幾乎就所有漲了多的票
幾乎全部都是半導體
所以你相當於
原來Momentum買的這些票被
原來買的票是整個市場
有各種幹的股票
那現在這個買的Momentum買的票
其實大部分都是在
其實大部分都在半導體裡
你等於把半導體一下子拉起來
然後砸下去
所以現在到底平常評了多少這個問題
就是現在平常可能回到了4月份的水平
就是讓這個市場回到4月份水平
那有沒有
因為3月份開始漲
那個Momentum的這個根漲
其實從3月份開始
然後把它
Momentum根漲是從3月份的漲了以後
開始跟進去
才去全部去買到半導體
那麼現在回到4月份的這個水平的話
並不能說它所有的槓桿全部出現了
那麼但是呢
就是現在處於一個稍微更加平衡一點的水平
在這個MomentumFact就市場上加槓桿
我們看到Gross margin很高
Net margin很低的情況
你可以看
現在的這個Gross margin
並沒有很低
現在還是在3倍多
3倍多你說比上去年年底的
不要說其他人比去年年底的水平
或者是去年年中的水平
都是高還是高很多
所以簡單來說
Momentum Hatter的平倉
應該還有兩個星期左右
就是這個是狗們講的
高生講的
就是可能至少還有兩個星期左右
就是這個平倉並沒有完全結束
那麼它對市場影響的
現在在變小
因為當你當量化暴倉
或者量化平倉
它把整個市場砸得非常低的時候
就把整個市場開始往下砸得好
砸得非常低的時候
是會有人很多人出來超低的
所以你對市場的影響
並沒有在高點就對市場影響這麼大
但是它的平倉盤肯定還沒有完全結束
這個是Momentum Hatter
那麼市場上的槓桿
其實不光是有Momentum
它還有ETF的Labrage
那我們之前講過
ETF的Labrage量非常的大
給一個比較直觀的數據
就ETF原來Labrage三筆
在半導體上的三筆
比方說兩倍做多海裡市
兩倍做多那個美光
兩倍做多什麼櫻桃之類這些東西
那個總的量大概在1,570億
這我寫了嗎
這沒寫1,570億
然後現在是940億
940億並不是一個非常非常低的數字
所以你如我從整體市場槓桿來說
它也沒有完全去趕緊
就是這個跟我上週的觀點
還是比較一致
就是你會不會整個市場
會不會最後把全部槓桿去掉
這個是不確定的事情
那麼我們知道在去槓桿過程中間
一開始最痛苦
那麼在去到現在這個時候
就是在半導體上的痛苦程度在下降
就是它繼續往下砸案能力在下降
但是它還有沒有槓位繼續砸
它還是有的
槓桿一般不會完全去趕緊
就是你即使08年
它也不是說那個要把ETF
Labrage ETF全部砸成0
對吧
但是我們更多的是要看
這個Labrage ETF
在砸下去的過程中
有沒有起很大的交易量
有沒有上週五是有起交易量
所以有沒有起很大交易量
這個時候有沒有更多的錢進去
進去把它買
那麼其實根據股價下跌
應該是賣出
那個780億
然後剛我說1570億減去940億
那就等於是640億
所以640億是實際的
相當於實際的Delabrage
那麼就意味著有150億在那裡買盤了
就是說這個是有資金進去買的
150億的資金進去買
那麼150億
而且去買的相當於是Labrage ETF
就相當於你槓桿在減少的時候
是你有超低的
所以我覺得就是說
這個後面就是繼續
得要去看一下後面
特別是明天開始谷歌要報業績
所以包括谷歌報了業績之後
然後HypeScale要出業績
這段時間裡面
它的在底部里面
就砸盤
大家都在觀望
因為後面我會講
後面有幾個懸在半空中不確定的事件
因為有這些不確定的事件
所以大部分資金都在觀望
觀望的時候
它砸盤其實砸了還是很兇的
那砸到某一個位置
投資人就開始願意進去買
就覺得業績好
就願意進去買
這個願意進去買的
這個資金的量
會不會形成一個比較大交易量
我覺得這個是判斷
Momentum的砸盤
對市場
其實並不是說Momentum
能不能全部打出來的
更多的是看
Momentum的砸盤
對於市場的影響力會不會下降
就算一個%
在過去
這個不是一年
這應該是三年
過去三年裡面
那個HatchFund
就是現在HatchFund的這個Labrage
和GrossModule的Labrage
GrossModuleLabrage
大概是5年95%的水平
然後HatchFund的Labrage
是過去三年裡面
82%的水平
就Percentile水平
所以整體的槓桿
肯定還是沒有非常的低了
就是現在槓桿率還是比較高的
你要是比較兇的去槓桿
還是可以取得下去的
所以站在宏觀上
就我們現在很隔離
就是宏觀上
確實是有上下的風險不勝對稱
就在往下跑的概率
往下
就往下可以跑的更多
然後但是在威觀上的
我們又是非常確定的
看到這些公司業界非常好
所以一直是處於一個比較規律的狀態
但我會講一下
我自己的看法
就是總體的看法
然後為什麼現在很多資金
不敢去買牌
其實有幾方面
第一個就是
它雖然跌了很多
但是有很多人講
vix沒有上來
意味著就是整個指數沒有跌
指數沒有跌
指數的波動力沒上來
vix現在波動力還只有18
這個數據基本上在18
雖然不在我們跟24年25年
這種低點的時候比
那個18不算特別低
但是你要把時間拉長的話
基本上還是在一個historical low上
還是在一個很低的地點上
那麼definitely這個18不能夠
就是你看到大家自己的
靜止的變化
就持股靜止的變化
這個18%肯定不像18%的樣子
所以你可以理解
就整個市場上
現在有correlation
就關聯度
被壓到非常非常低
所以現在更好的
我覺得交易上
更好的是做多股票的關聯度
然後做多債券的關聯度
這些關聯度
現在都被拉得非常非常低
然後現在這個市場
vix沒有上去
所以大家不敢買
第二個就是
我們看到CTA的賣牌和買牌
是非對稱性風
非對稱性的風險
就是它其實如果說兩個sigma
指數兩個sigma跌
這兩件事情是連在一起的
就你如果看到
這兩件事情就連在一起
你如果看到vix上升
然後股票指數
vix上升就代表股票指數下跌
股票指數下跌
就代表著那個CTA要賣出
然後
好像賣下去
還會發生Nectar感冒
就腹感冒
賣出賣1,400億
所以你整個指數
有這樣的一個風險
不對稱性的風險的時候
大家看到
個股已經跌了很多了
就不太敢去買
這個是阻止很多買牌的
一個很重要的原因
現在那個
就這個事物
別人是買laborgy tf
現在雖然按老題跌了很多
你就問為什麼
他跌了很多
沒有進行b反
因為momentum factor的頻盤
他就不太會b反
你看momentum factor
就是高盛的momentum factor的指數
已經跌了非常多
就我買多一般來說
我比方說去買多一個
籃子的股票
然後我賣空另外一個籃子
就是我把s&p全部羅列起來
我買多1千萬分之5
然後賣空後1萬分之5
他會有一個我們叫lag
會有一個延後的
就我舉個例子
就是msei的那個momentum
momentum指數
他是觀察過往12個月
然後他把最近那個月給剔除的
所以你一開始下跌的時候
他可能沒有調整
但是你調整到他的
因為這個factor波動太大了
這個factor波動一大的時候
他被強平了
強平的時候
他就重新rebalance就調整
rebalance調整
這個是導致我們現在
第一波下跌的最主要原因
但是你畢竟還是跌了一個月了
有很多的股票
他已經不在momentum裡面了
就是你跌了
所以你導致你不在那個momentum裡
然後你會在下一次調倉的時候
被調出去
而不是被調進來
然後如果說調倉結束
比方說去看看結束
他會不會馬上買回你賣掉的股票
那未必
因為你已經不是漲了最多的那個了
你被殺了30%
你不一定是漲了最多的那個
所以不一定會把你買回來
這個東西
就momentum的一般這個調整
就是他的這個調整以後
就因為momentum大規模調整
沒有發生過很多次
超過20%的
這個指數超過20%的調整
在過往可能80年以來
就發生過11次
發生過11次
然後通常漲回到高點
就完全漲回來
要4到6個月
因為確實這裡面很多公司
是業績是很不錯的
但是momentum不是看你業績買的
它就是看你漲了多買
就大部分的這個量化的倉位
它是看你漲了多
並不是跟中國的那些量化一樣
我分析
量化還分析這公司的基本面
我先經流
然後我去買那些公司
做空指數
它不是這麼做的
他們就是看量價
看你漲了多的更買
然後跌了多
我就賣空你
那這些要回來
需要基本面把那個公司再推回來
然後這些momentum才會買回來
所以我們說5月份到6月份
因為3、4月份漲了多
5月份6月份那次
讓我們所有的算的籌碼
無效的賣盤
更多的就是這些無腦的momentum的賣盤
那麼你怎麼上去
你怎麼下來
那你下來以後
你要讓這些錢重新回去
它有個過程
它沒有那麼快
所以我是覺得就是在投資上面
你要去看什麼時候去買哪些的票
就是其實一個我這補充一個我心得了
就我覺得在一個去槓桿的時候
會有很多次非常巨大的反彈
巨大的反彈的時候
它已經是此毛條會跳到很快的
然後但是什麼叫做反
就是這個delab去結束
去槓桿結束
然後真正開始比較長的反彈的時候
它的漲幅
它不應該是所有股票一起漲
它應該是一個sector一個sector漲
就好像我們在3月份的時候看到一樣
就是你一開始可能是存儲
對吧
然後一開始光好像三月份
一開始光存儲
然後CPU開始漲intel AMD
代理CPU開漲
然後又是存儲
然後電子元配件
也電子旗艦什麼之類的
所以它是就相當於我有很
我需要有很大的網上充的動能
但是這個動能的不能過一下子
浪費在所有的股票上
你要一下子浪費
將所有的股票往上漲
你長久不了幾天
所以這個我覺得因為
而且你沒有像5月份6月份這種
momentum的動能
這個就是量化的動能
然後量化資金不停的
無腦筋來幫你把它拉上去
我覺得現在是沒有的
所以如果說是
因為現在很多的半導體的
固執確實還是很低的
然後如果是看好這個行業
不然看好業來的話
你可以容忍自己在下地的時候
miss out的一點東西
就掉了一點
我覺得都沒有關係
然後如果你錯過
比方說下周一條業績很好
你錯過了
那你可以去買AMD
你可以去買AMD
如果下地也都可以買AMD
你可以反過來去買
光
你可以去買不同的行業
就是它的會輪動
就真正的上漲
它是會輪動
所以不是那麼怕錯過
那麼是不是跌到頭呢
那我跌到頭是不是跌到頭
最兇的肯尼果雕
就跌到最兇的肯尼果雕
momentum 底拉布爾
確實是肯尼果雕
這個底拉布爾
會不會讓它繼續下跌
那個有可能
就是它還要去兩個星期
但我覺得後面關注的焦點
不是在我們今天看到量化包裝
momentum factor 2.1
後面關注的焦點
就是我後面要講
其實是RO
那我快看
我有沒有寫
我沒有寫快點
不好意思
就是其實是在ROI和KAPEX出來以後
對於信貸的影響
這個事情
我們之前也講過很多很多次
就是其實現在市場上
沒有很多的錢
你包括看到Henix一共融了26個別臉
Henix融了26個別臉
然後其實主要是它融的
把那個整個momentum factor給打爆了
你在漲的特別高的時候
你的趨勢
等於趨勢跟中
趨勢漲的特別高的時候
它一下子融很多錢
然後它把這個趨勢給逆軟
那其實這個東西沒有多少錢
加上CDS
我們之前一直講
就是你要去買信貸
因為我現在缺錢
就是原來沒有供應
本質是原來沒有債群的供應
現在忽然多出來很多債群的供應
原來我給個數碗
就原來一年
那個CDS供應大概180個別臉
然後現在可能一年超過過去五年
明年要超過再過去10年
就因為這種規模在增加
那原來你所有Hyper Scaler的CDS很低
是因為沒有供應量
那麼後面的供應量一旦上來
就是你會有一個信用的擠壓
但是我今天想說
其實不是我之前講的
很多信用擠壓的問題
它真正發生信用擠壓
是擠壓在外面
就我覺得這個點
在很多在炒Hyper Scaler
或者是看空
我其實也很很空
我也覺得Hyper Scaler融資
它的信用和股票都要出問題
那但為什麼我對AR還是很暴
很暴很比較樂觀的觀點
因為我覺得是這樣子
包括我們現在出來的
那個新的開源的模型
這一幾個大廠
它在投入酸力中心的時候
它至少賬面ROI是很高的
它比投製造也和投其他行業
都要高很多
意味著即使CDS
只要沒有到一個可不能承受的水平
比方說亞馬遜的CDS升到100個點
它還是會融資去做CAPEX
明天谷歌要出CAPEX
它現在市場consensus
覺得它26年是186個別列
然後我們得知的情況
在26年可能是230個別列
所以這個規模是非常非常不小
那這個是內部
它Google可能他們裡面的那個
就是覺得的預期
不是Finance
不是CFO出來講的預期
就是他們對於產線
對於它可能需要的算力
他們估的可能是230個別列左右
所以他們還是會融很多錢
我說的是
他們融了這個錢
做了算力中心還是能夠賺錢
從賬面上肯定能賺錢
市場上看空它是看空它的問題
就好像歐洲口一樣
然後市場上給我融資成本高
我融資成本高了
我可能還是想去做
取決用融資成本高到什麼地步
它引爆市場
它並不是我
就這四個雲場
和歐洲口是不一樣的
真相的引爆市場的時候
它不是說我融資成本
到了300個點
500個點
然後我真的到了500個點
導致我沒有辦法做CAPEX
而是說我覺得更多的是
整個IG的快樂市場
會被這五個公司的大量的需求
然後給充高
這個危險更大
這個危險其實超過這五個公司
自己的CDS升到很高的水平
也就是Amazon在120個點的時候
它還會去融資做CAPEX
但是原來120個點
融資成本是銀行的
至少是120個還是大行的
不是小行
大行可能5年100個點
80到120個點在這個水平裡
如果亞馬遜的融資成本變得更高
那它還會擠中小銀行
或者是製藥企業
或者是原來做基建的那些人的
融資就是融資池
因為IG就是我們叫做投資級的債券
它的池是一個池子
它會讓所有的公司的快樂市場全部上去的
就這個東西它像什麼
它就是像我們今天在講MLCC
我們今天在講那個Ned
在那邊那個成主
我們很多人在炒Ned
炒MLCC炒電容
然後炒各種各樣的這個原配件
那真正我說的缺錢的是什麼
真正缺的這個市場缺的
下游所有的那個半導體行業
其實硬缺進缺全部在缺
你說成主光CPU、GPU
CPU現在已經翻倍
你能夠高端CPU、MAC加幅物器都已經翻倍
然後全部在缺
但是真正缺的是資金提供的人
但是資金提供的人
它也會優先給AI
如果AI的價錢OK的話
像現在亞馬遜
現在亞馬遜的60幾個點
6、70個點
然後亞馬遜如果到6、70個點
它不一定
因為最近漲了太多了
30幾個點漲上來
但是如果說你能夠真的給到100多點
我肯定願意借給你
那我可能就不借給銀行
整個信貸市場的快樂 spread上升
幾十個點
這個是災難性的
就比較快的時間
如果上升幾十個點
是災難性的
你不能說過去5年10年
我們的整個IG快樂 spread在一個地位
所以我們就能夠適應這個環境
人就整個企業的生態
在不同的環境裡面
它環境迅速切換
它就沒有辦法適應
就好像我們現在沒有辦法適應
回到80年的那個18%的利息一樣
那我們曾經經歷過這個
對曾經快樂 spread是在300個點
就IG200點、300個點
但是現在如果整體上升幾十個點
對於實體其實是災難性的
這個是市場
就我們往前看
更往前看
信貸市場是一個問題
然後這個和美聯儲的市場
就是說我們叫做利率市場
其實也是關聯的
就是它總是會產生幾下效應
就好像它今天在消費電子產生幾下效應一樣
但是它產生幾下效應
在實體經濟上會有個災難的結果
所以意味著政策制定著
我不管是白工還是Fed
它最終是要放錢
這個看法和市場大部分的頭髮很不一樣
大家覺得開文博士商量做QT
對吧
它可以做QT
然後甚至它不做QE就行
就它肯定大概是不會做QE
它可以做QT或補作
但是它要讓錢能夠流出來
所以它要么就進行更大規模的去見管
或者就把銀行手放開
或者它做其他的動作
像說特朗普去搞一個類似Fed Mac
或Fed Mac類似的這種淡保機構
我不知道
這是它需要讓這個市場去應對這個資金的擠壓
信貸市場資金擠壓
我覺得是一個比較危險的事情
那麼說到這個問題
就回到我們剛最後我們講的
就是美聯儲的態度
美聯儲在下周末
下周二的時候要開7月份的機器會議
所以7月份的機器會議
我這沒有顯媒聯儲
沒關係
然後這裡
然後它開7月份的機器會議
所以大部分人現在覺得7月份要申請
就我是覺得今年你就是申請一次
也沒啥
7月份大概率是不會升
大概率是不會升
但聯儲裡面的這個分歧還是蠻大的
那美聯儲最擔心的CPI的數據
其實我覺得CPI的當算會比
就是我們叫做CPI的下行風險
是超過上行的
這CPI本身是一個非常智厚的一個指標
就你今天看到的純粹的CPI的上個月的時候
是其實因為油價這些東西上升
但是比方說Shout比方說人力
我們就Shout和人力
就是一個service
一個是房租
一個服務業
一個房租
這兩個東西其實往上跑的力量很小
跑的就能夠繼續往上跑的空間已經很小
美國就位上沒有那麼的好
所以KamenWash它剛剛進聯儲
它需要去建立自己的信用
就建立自己的credit
它可能講得比較強硬
但是實際的情況是
美國的CPI的數據實際上是往下跑的
經濟其實基本面也有可能往下跑
特別是回到我們剛剛講的CPI的壓力的問題
所以你在宏觀層面
確實有很多不確定下
大家不敢下單是有道理的
不敢下單一個是美聯儲
你態度沒有明確
你到底是深吸馬
人生多長
不明確
第二個信貸市場的問題
一直沒有辦法給到市場一個解決方案
這個還只是Google
因為我寫Google
是下星期要出業的
但是4個hyperscale加在一起
今年要融3000億
今年要融個3000億
然後明年要融個5000億
再加上8月份的時候
10月份的時候
做錯了8月份
就是10月份的時候
Andopia肯定要融資
OPAI融了那麼多錢
Andopia上來只要融個2000到3000億
就你看到的Henix對市場的抽血
那只有260億
就他的Andia的影響
我還沒說完
我就說一下韓國Andia影響
他的Andia的影響
就是可置換Andia的影響
還沒有出來
那但是你前端有這麼多的融資盤需求
其實這個才是阻止了
現在市場大部分的錢進去的原因
就是美股並不是真正的缺這個200億
或者是甚至不是缺那2000億
它是說你前面有大量的錢需求
然後你沒聯儲的態度
我知道你聯儲這麼好
是你不出手是這個問題好像很難解決
就今年的夠解決
今年明年
後年總歸在某個時點
你要你不出手
沒有這個我感覺你很難解決
所以大部分的錢
在momentum factor and wine的時候
它採取了觀望的態度
就我不敢再
而且你漲了很多
我不敢在那位置接盤
接下去的分歧是宏觀和微觀
就是宏觀上看到這些問題
就是大家不敢出手的問題
懸而未決還沒有解決
有可能後面會解決
但是微觀上看到公司業這條
就是我說一下兩個可以大規模入場
然後很大的倉位去買的一個兩個情況
就我覺得第一個就是VIX上升
就是你整個指數開始跌跌了很多
然後整個指數上升跌了很多以後
那個本身就跌了比較多的半導體
其實性價比會更高
所以你等於是把前方一個雷給排掉
但是VIX上升的時候
半導體不一定會有很多
因為它確實已經跌過了
然後已經跌過以後
你可能會看到比方說
指數在那裡跌10個點
半導體也就跌10個點
有可能會看到這種情況
所以這是一種情況
第二個就是我們看到Momentum更多的被屏藏
這個數據它不一定會馬上下來的
有一些屏藏以後它會變反向
就是你既然是跌了最多的做空
漲了最多的做多
它會把它反過來變成做空半導體的
但是半導體的業績是真的很好
就是所有這些企業的業績是真的很好
那你反過來做空它的時候
業績爆發是非常容易被打爆的
就反向的被打爆了
所以你可能會
我覺得 somehow如果繼續下跌
繼續下跌的下挫力沒有那麼大
它並不是能夠像這裡一樣
往下打了30個點
就是整個Momentum的指數
往下打了35點
就你看了AR那些懲處
光那些東西被打了35個點
你沒有能力再往下打35點
這個Definitely沒有能力
甚至往下打十幾個點都很難
然後但是你把倉位如果打反過來的話
它業績一好也可能會爆
你可能Momentum
會這個Factor會爆倉
因為它現在做空的是半導體了
所以這種情況是我覺得第二種可能性
所以觀察這兩個是可以非常決定的進去蠻
第三個就是如果你對於長期覺得沒有問題
就是並不是交易層面的倉位
長期沒有問題
那我覺得長期沒有問題
長期沒有問題的話
現在半導體的固執都不算高
就你要覺得AR不解鎖
就是快樂的問題不爆發的話
AR現在固執都不爆
但是這個前提是信貸問題不炸掉
信貸問題你依賴就是連處
它是不會讓它炸掉的
然後最後說一下Kimi
就是覺得今天我多講幾分鐘
最後說一下Kimi
因為我覺得這比較重要
Kimi的模型非常好用
然後也很強
但是Kimi在公佈之後
中國已經沒有算力
也就是說
我覺得不應該把Kimi和Deep Seek做一個比較
Deep Seek當時大部分的算力投入在訓練的
所以Deep Seek講的故事是說
我可以用更低的成本給你完成這個訓練
所以我們可能不需要那麼多算力
不需要那麼多訓練
所以當時的半導體就包括主要是因為大
DLF就是大點
但是Deep SeekKimi不會有這個影響
Kimi是個開源模型
現在主賽道已經回到推理Infra上面去
所以在Infra上
你能不能用更少的參數
用更少的內存
用更少的算力
然後完成你Kimi的就算
不行
Kimi是2.8T的一個大模型
它部署在本地機已經沒可能了
我用GLM
我拿兩台大機器還能夠部署一下
然後但是Kimi你哪怕拿
英偉大的工作站都部署不了
就這個東西2.8T
你除以4
你就算除以4
你也得700多劑吧
700多劑你H100的10張卡
你8張卡都不行
所以必須是回到雲場
那麼對於雲場來講
他們在做ROI的時候
你回到那個谷歌搞ROI
那個他們在做ROI的時候
對於雲場來說
它是需要
它是希望有兩個大客戶
還是有20個客戶
或者他有
就不一定算是客戶
因為這是開源模型
其實你不一定完全要用Kimi公司的那個接口
不一定要去租給Kimi公司
你可以自己在上面部署
所以雲場我有兩個模型
而且這兩個是私有的模型
相當於兩個大客戶
還是我有三五個模型號
那對於雲場肯定是後者更好
就是這個事情
市場可能需要一定的時間的反饋
但是開源模型變得更好
對於算力投入其實是個積極的情況
所以你如果回到公司本層
公司層
像這個谷歌
或者是那個Hyper Scala Microsoft
Amazon他們
他們是從公司層面
是會就這次業績中間
我也講到這次業績的憂鬱期
他們可能是會比較積極的繼續去搞投入的
但是唯一的製撤走就是借錢錢在哪裡
所以AI還是廣廣向前
你看這個模型進步還是非常
就開源模型的進步
其實對整個AI是一個好事情
把token cost的下降
對整個AI也是個好事情
這個東西因為背後都是需要算力的
所以半導體背後其實是算力
它並不完全是模型
所以是算力
但是短期裡面
anthropic業績下降
大家會怕
短期裡面大家缺貨
就是我們叫Uanato缺貨
就是給錢的人缺貨
快樂市場的缺貨
大家會怕
我覺得現在在半導體裡面最大的風險
可能就是信貸
還有就是信貸對非半導體
非AI的這個基礎
好吧
那我今天先講到這裡
謝謝大家的時間
我今天就不開源了
我覺得可能已經沒有時間了
好吧
謝謝